yeah
[Music]
I've been a professional web developer
for 24 years almost and when I started
it was all fields it was really all
fields all interactivity we had on the
web was HTML elements that you type
something in you send it off to the
server to go to your PHP not PHP even
Perl ASP for the really terrible people
and Java and whatever on the back end
and render more HTML out
that's why HTML was never seen as
something sensible it was seen as
something that a better language should
render out and these web developers are
people that we don't really care about
and then we added labels to fields we
didn't add labels for accessibility
which we should because nobody cared
back then but actually what we did we
had JavaScript out of a sudden and
JavaScript allowed us to create
interactivity in the browser and become
real developers on the front and side
the problem with JavaScript though was
that we we all of a sudden didn't want
to be web developers anymore we wanted
to show that we're better than that with
something new javascript gives us the
power that we always wanted so we
created lots of labels around our
JavaScript work first was just
JavaScript then it was D HTML dynamic
HTML and then we said it's better it's
bad doing D HTML because it's only for
one browser and not for the other and
it's really relying on JavaScript so we
called it on obtrusive javascript then
flash came around then we called it Dom
scripting then ajax was the next cool
thing and comment was a thing that
flashed past and didn't leave a mark but
it was there and if one thing was that
the the way we learned these things was
a very simple way of thinking about a
logical order we learned two things
first we looked up what's in JavaScript
what the possibilities in JavaScript are
and then we actually started developing
with it we created something in the
browser and we actually found out what's
going on there but there was a lot of
testing and trying things out was it
professional what we did absolutely not
but it was creative it was wonderful it
was a brave new world of something new
that we haven't done before and the real
thing is we couldn't even test or we
couldn't even know we're doing customer
no debugging tools that he buggin who
wasn't
and then you sometimes had a loop where
you get stuck in the alert and he had to
shut down your browser or your computer
even back then and then out of a sudden
we certainly need debugging tools and
Firebug came around and then developer
tools in the browser came around and out
of a sudden we could do everything in
the browser we could learn something we
could develop and we can debug in the
browser it was great and then we added
abstractions because differences in
browsers made us not as effective as we
thought we should be so we came up with
libraries Ajax libraries jQuery all
these things that people used and still
still use sadly enough a lot of them are
out there and made our life easier then
we realized we create far too much code
that way and we rely on far too many
things so we created build processes in
essence we wrote more code to undo the
code that we've written too much for our
end users because our end users should
not suffer our creativity
so nowadays it's a totally different
world we always say we're developers
were developing things but what we
mostly do is depend on other things
we're using other people's code to build
our code to create things that are
bigger and better than ours standing on
the shoulders of giants as some people
say and that sometimes is a problem
cause the debugging doesn't work as
easily as it used to because we're not
creating the JavaScript that we're
debugging sometimes we have to know
where it comes from from the abstraction
from the third-party thing from that
10500 sixteenth-note module that we just
included because it's safe and why not
and the learning thing is mostly about
the platform the abstraction of the
platform not the platform itself I can't
keep up with what's in CSS and what's in
JavaScript anymore because I'm too weak
to tempt 'add to use this react that
view these kind of things and the
platform has moved on we've got great
things we've got wonderful things in the
platform itself and it should be enough
to build something good but we always
want to be better so we kind of caught
in the rush of the new thing the new and
shiny the better thing the web is broken
we need to do a virtual Dom we need to
do a virtual this we need to do that
better and that better
why are browsers so slow because you
don't use the platform and we cannot
actually make the platform better if
it's not being used and in essence we're
focusing on the wrong thing we should be
focusing on our end users the end users
out there are there for us to actually
have a living they pay our companies for
the things that we create our job is to
build things to allow people to do
things that's it we're delivery service
it's not about us it's about the
end-users that we're there and these are
people with horrible browsers terrible
environments really bad connectivity
with physical disabilities with problems
in their eyesight with all kind of
things that we have to deal with and it
is not about us it's about our tech
legacy I work a lot with enterprise and
legacy companies right now and I see a
lot of old code that is unlocked
untouched not being used by anybody but
by millions of users and nobody
maintains that anymore because we're too
busy chasing the next thing so the tech
legacy that we leave behind the products
that actually lock people out because of
their ability because of their language
because of their location on the planet
is actually giving us a bad reputation
Tech has does not have a good reputation
nowadays back days when I started with
the geeks nobody cared about then we
were the cool innovators of that cool
new thing called web and now we're like
ah that's like the bankers of the 80s
it's a horrible elitist group of people
that actually are hard to get into the
weird thing is that developers are
people - most of them actually and I
like people most of my friends are
people dogs are better but people
developers are people too so we don't
actually see as much patience for other
developers as we see for our end users
we have thousands of performance talks
how to make your products fast we don't
have many talks how easy it is to become
a developer and to maintain and to join
an open-source project and actually
start playing in this world there's not
enough information about that out there
and of course we have an overload as
developers we demanded people ask us to
actually know about performance
know about security accessibility and so
on and so forth nobody can know all of
this we're pretending we do or we
specialize in one of them and then blame
others that they're not good at it but
nobody can do that we're just feeling
overwhelmed by the time I look at
something in hacker news and I'm like eh
I got to take a look at that and then by
the time I have time to look at it
somebody said don't use it any longer
and I feel like I'm out of touch I don't
know what's going on anymore I probably
should be a goat farmer or something
like that and we don't actually work
with these things we don't care about
performance security accessibility and
these kind of things too much we
actually work on faith we hope that the
framework that were using has all of
that built-in performance of course when
it's when when the the framework scales
for Facebook it probably is good for
that website I did for that florist as
well accessibility like they probably
have thought of that as well
we actually not doing it we're hoping
that the magic of the framework and the
abstractions takes away all that that
those thinking from us and I think we're
missing a lot of opportunity a lot of
growth that we had at the beginning of
the market where people came in sideways
from nowhere from like that they weren't
they didn't go to university they didn't
learn about computers they just wanted
to build things for the web at peri web
but the first one one of the best talks
I've given I had that chatter had with
somebody about JavaScript was a physical
architect asking me how to architect
code and it was just this is bizarre but
he had wonderful ideas sideways ideas
that I put in a framework back then but
we gave up on that to a degree we say
like you gotta you gotta use that or
you're not a full developer not a
hundred-percent developer a quick story
about this the other day somebody
emailed me
well pink me on Twitter and say like oh
I wonder I want to have this project can
you take a look at the website if it's
actually good one HTML document a simple
HTML document with a few SVG images in
it and he's like yeah see if the content
if the message works and I found if a
typo in there I'm not okay I'm a good
citizen of the web I go to github I
[ __ ] this thing I downloaded and I
built it on my own machine and fix that
typo for that person
to be a nice person hundred fifty
megabyte of note dependencies were
downloaded for a single HTML document
and then it didn't work because I used
it on my ubuntu box then I did it on my
Mac again and it worked but I ended up
item not caring anymore I went to get up
press the edit button edit it directly
there sent the press reader to request
there and I'm on a fast computer I'm on
a good connectivity imagine me being a
Bangladeshi developer who wants to join
an open-source project and the first
thing that person encounters is 150
megabyte of random code that doesn't
mean anything
for fixing a typo we should be better
than that we have amazing technology and
yet nobody's happy a lot of people are
overloaded with like I don't want to
join this group of people that just have
150 megabyte of random stuff and we
basically oh if people don't know about
node and and NPM they don't know CSS
what but you get these like people like
oh you've got to be professional you got
to know that and that we have stopped
playing with the platform itself
we stopped creating CSS hacks to work
around issues with the browser we
stopped thinking about JavaScript
solutions that our JavaScript rather
than just another module another
abstraction I keep calling us nowadays
to full stack overflow developers
because you just when you don't know
something you go to stack overflow you
copy and paste that obviously secure and
perfect code and you put it inside your
thing and then it works so what went
wrong where is where is the problem
where's the worst et happiness gone
where's the finding something out gone
the power that we had back then I think
we have too much choice and that's a
good thing but it's also an overwhelming
thing and I'm working on developer tools
right now and when I see this I'm
excited what we have in there I also
have no idea what 80% of these things
are when you look at the statistics in
developer tools what people are using
it's like 10% of all the offers in there
there's things five menus deep that are
really really amazing and our
click-through rate shows nobody ever
looked at that thing
but somebody on a conference set we
built this in there everybody clapped
everybody got excited and said like
finally we have this tool we have great
debugging in these things breakpoints
what do people use console.log another
problem that I think is that context
switching is mentally exhausting I go
from my editor to my browser I go to the
to the website to read up some
documentation and I don't know what when
something's going or to stack overflow
to copy and paste it then I go to the
command line to actually do all might
get commands and I jump in between these
contexts all the time it feels like cool
you know like we I know the matrix and I
know that but at the same time we
mentally exhausted by jumping between
all these things we're also spending far
too much time customizing all of those
how many blog posts have you probably
seen the last few months what is the
best dark theme for your text editor and
you're not a professional developer if
you don't use that font with those
ligatures in your in your developer
environment you're like what the hell is
going on so I think it's time to rethink
tooling I think our tools the things
that the developers should prevent us
from doing things wrong instead of
patching up what we created that thing
that in the beginning that I showed that
like we learn we create and then we
actually debug why is this actually so
disconnected from each other I'd rather
see a world where we have the learning
as part of the debugging and the
developing because we've been doing this
for 20 years we know a lot of things
that are wrong we know a lot of things
how to fix them we put them on our blogs
we put them in like great articles and
books and hopes people find them why
don't we put them where people are using
things right now so an idea of holistic
developer tools a lightweight
pre-configured and open to feedback and
contribution developer tool online
things like code pen jsbin stack blitz
code sandbox these are great these are
wonderful I want to try out SAS ok go
download SAS installed on your computer
mess up your your file system hopefully
something works oh it didn't work
afternoon is gone you know
gonna try sass I just go to jsbin say
Priya pre-compiled SS type in some sass
oh cool this is what sass is most of
what we do nowadays does not work
offline anymore you need to run a local
server anyways so why are our
development environment not also on the
web and there are many out there that
are there and I see incredibly creative
people like on a two-door and people
like that that only work in those they
don't have anything installed on their
computer because they'll just go online
and start typing and do cool stuff
because all editors that we have
nowadays that are not these C++
installable things anymore most of them
are actually electron engines or
JavaScript systems that run inside the
browser so all of them work online and
can be edited by us I loved when a home
site came out in 1997 1998 because it
was written in a script you know
Microsoft's redheaded stepchild of
JavaScript back then and nowadays all
these are hackable
Adson was to first want to be hackable
vias code is written in typescript you
can actually have changed that editor to
your needs we have the browser developer
tools in the browser also written in
typescript and they're actually remote
editable so you can just run them in the
background you can have a browser a
headless browser as just an instance
running from your code you don't have to
go to the browser anymore you can have
to see results from the browser and the
documentation that we have like the MDM
and can I use of this world all have
api's so this is super powerful and
flexible because we can mix and match
those things to make environments where
people learn while they are developing
for example you can't know everything as
I said there's lots of stuff
accessibility performance and so on so
how about we have in context
documentation and linting while we are
coding this is a Visual Studio code you
see there's these probably on that
screen and oh no yeah there's little red
squiggly lines under that it's like when
you type something wrong in word this is
annoying you know something is wrong
there
so you hover over that and then you
realize for example this button element
is a button element it is a button
labeled by its content but as browsers
are sometimes terrible you also have to
give a button
button which seems redundant but it's
the only way to make it work across
browsers and that is one of those tests
you don't know but now you know to get
that squiggly line away from you output
is not supported by Internet Explorer
okay but it's still interesting to know
an output element might not work in this
environment where you want to have it
and when you type an image in without an
alternative text it tells you images
need alternative text and we don't do
that
we hope that browsers generate something
with AI or something and I love that I
become a better developer since I used
that kind of environment because I'm not
putting wrong things into the debugging
flow and of putting wrong things into
production I just learn things while I'm
doing it and I'm not doing them wrong
any longer context switch thing that
I've talked before is tiring as well
this is another instance where I can use
a browser in the background run it as a
headless browser so it opens up the
browser window then it goes away and I
get a preview inside my editor itself of
that browser that is fully interactive
and I can start now doing my debugging
and my CSS tweaking inside my editor how
often have you written some CSS went to
the browser open the developer tools
tweaked the numbers around until it
looked right and then went back to the
editor just to realize that it was
generated CSS that you actually tried to
edit if you setup your project in this
way you can test it in your development
environment and your sass or less or
whatever updates automatically from it
even while your idea we said earlier
Stack Overflow will go to stack overflow
and just copy and paste code computers
can do that better for us this is
another environment that I've been using
and I've been working on we're now in
this case Python it actually scrapes
from the 3,000 most up voted projects or
most successful projects in github and
automatically autocompletes the code
from you while you're typing it in there
so it turns Python into a typed language
which is crazy thinking but at the same
time we do that by hand now we don't
even know what we're putting in there at
least in this case we could also
automatically test if it's secure so I'm
sorry I have no easy answers I have
nothing to
give you to say like oh this is the
future of it but I know that an open
mind and with open ears and an open
source environment we can fix this we
can get as excited as I was when I
started because automation is happening
everywhere people are worried about
their jobs are worried about what we
build taking their jobs away so this is
probably a good time to make it easier
for people to become a developer by
using these systems and not telling them
to go and read it up this is your world
to build the editor the browser and the
Docs that teach people great practices
viola developing not after they messed
it up thank you
[Applause]
[Music]